mit dir wir beide lebenslange ich komme
wie ein buch und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video liebe leute es gibt da
draußen im internet so eine app die
kennt vielleicht ein paar von euch
ich habe jetzt ein letztes davon gehört
habe nie benutzt und zwar kinder und was
den allgemein macht für die davon noch
nichts gehört haben kinder ist oder wo
menschen sich quasi kennenlernen und
eigentlich ist dafür gedacht dass leute
sich wirklich nur kennenlernen wird aber
manchmal für andere dinge missbraucht
sondern auf dieser seite gibt es
menschen die einfach katastrophal
verpacken und das schauen wir zum
heutigen video an ich weiß auch was das
ganze in der serie ist bullshit tv
teenager zu bei denen deswegen habe ich
eine beschreibung meine pace verlinken
videos von denen es heißt wenn ich das
und mehr davon sehen wollten die fälle
sollen ab und mache dafür in eurem leben
fangen wir an leute ich hab ich auch die
seiten wo ich diese fans gefunden hat
und in der beschaffung verlinkt ok
irgendwie es los leute wir haben nix
schreibt you're on track also gehst du
laufen machst du so leichtathletik sie
antwortet nein warum habe ich früher
gemacht
der wirt vertrag einfach nicht dann
schreibt er ich hoffe dass einige von
euch nicht so weit in englisch sind dass
sie das direkt verstehen was auf deutsch
staffellauf heißt also was auch
leichtathletik ist ein staffellauf man
rennt herum gibt es ein staffelholz
weiter
das heißt auf englisch ich weiß nichts
mehr dazu
da wir die nächsten die kommen von jan
jan scherrer 9 bis 2015 traum von dem
traumfrau gefunden und dann kommt die
antwort sondern später willst du mich
verarschen genau das gleiche hast du
eben eine mittlerin schnell ein paar als
antwort darauf
bock auf den drei hat gut an der stelle
steht youtube kanal leute der nächste
fehler herkommen von einem gewissen
antonio tunjic gott nicht wirklich sehen
will der ist wirklich sehen klar ich
möchte nicht um den brei reden also ich
will ehrlich sein ich suche eine nette
dame für skype die mich wo die richtung
in die es gar nicht gefällt mir
behaupten die mich beobachtet ich
besitze 3
es geht weiter mit des ständers ich
hoffe dass nicht genommen weil dieses
video wird auch von ein paar jüngere
menschen gesehen deswegen denn es mache
einfach mal keine scheiße ok erstmals
schreibt ja 20 nach acht morgens
wer ist 20 jahre alt morgens in flotter
fahrt okay du bist einsam ich bin einsam
darf ich dich ich kann nicht mal lesen
was den unterschied macht es einfach
nicht dennis nach es einfach nicht
weitergehen
nächste nachricht dass kein name dabei
hey du kleine mary an
ich bin jetzt gerade dein größter fan
bei kinder habe ich dich entdeckt und
trinkt darauf eine pulle sekt das tut
auch innerlich weh dass vorzulesen ich
finde dich echt richtig gebaut
gestern war cap index mit dir wir beide
lebenslange ich komme wie ein gott sei
dank hat die dame an der stelle nicht
geantwortet nächste nachricht der mann
der mensch war ich habe also schlau
genug seinen namen nicht zu zeigen und
nicht auf einem kanal das aber auch geil
ja angenommen ich werde ein mensch der
schon mal diese app installiert gehabt
hat dann wäre eventuell auf menschen
gestoßen auf dieser seite die essen als
profilbilder haben sie so auch so viel
in diesem fall
dabei entsteht einfach nicht bleiben
dürfte suche nach meinem freund und
junge leute haben wir noch einen netten
abschluss für dieses bezaubernde video
via und dance schreiben sie ja mit der
nachricht eines ganzen und drin ist ich
denke man sich denn normalerweise eher
weniger an der stelle habe ich euch
gerne brachten da draußen einen sehr
schönen restlichen angenehm montag
menschen